huh another exciting episode of king of
the statues will begin right after this
bang intro today I got a special treat
for you guys um my art skills came in
and I think you're gonna love it
therefore mine studios there are three
pieces I'm a guy that really loves the
Hulk so if you look at a lot of my
statues my statues will involve the Hulk
they will involve Thor will involve like
juggernaut very strong characters that's
what I tend to read those are the books
that I tend to gravitate to so without
further ado I give you iron Studios 1/10
scale budget format statues now these
statues come in a budget form budget
form meaning that you can get them for
$89 to $100 depending on the size of the
statue they're all 1/10 but some come in
various degrees of scale so these are
art statues these are statues that you
can get and you can place them on your
shelves they don't need a lot of space
they take up of every small footprint
and you're able to display them all
about a lot of them come indoor Aramis
door Aramis are statues that go together
but sold separately most of the time
sometimes you can get a door Rama that's
made with the two statutes together this
story today has to do with thor ragnarok
right and also one door Rama piece that
I did pick up was for the Wakanda fight
with the Hulk in it now that one I only
got that one piece I didn't want all the
the set that came with I think it was
like ten different pieces and I only
gravitated towards the Hulk and that set
because if it's a Hawk statue I really
need to get it alright so but in the
Thor Ragnarok statue set the door Rama
the Hulk and Thor battling in the arena
they captured that very well so what I'm
gonna do first is I'm going to show you
the thought statue so here's the thought
statue and the cost statute looks very
premium it looks very nice
it was 89.95 from sideshow and it's made
from iron studios again they're looking
at the budget-conscious collector the
collector that needs to have his statue
there I want to represent but maybe
don't want to spend too much money or
maybe that doesn't have enough space so
look at the Thor give you a nice turn
around and then we have the Hulk this is
the Hulk with the statue give you the
unboxing the nice turn around as you can
see the Hulk's level of detail is
incredible there is also a screwin
hammer that I found to be very ingenious
because you always worry about the
hammer piece falling off or breakage in
the mail when they're shipping and there
was absolutely zero breakage because
when you separate the heavy piece and
you can screw it on there you go you
eliminate that one issue in shipping
also you have the Hulk from the wakandan
today this Hulk is highly detailed if
you look at a lot of the pitches you can
see the mud and the grime on the Hulk
hands now
he was never present inside that movie
to the fight which I fun but
they took liberties with it because he
was supposed to be in the movie I guess
they did extensive reshoots and they
changed a couple of the storylines of it
where the Hulk didn't show up an actual
battle but when you saw the trail and
leading up to it you saw the Hulk
fighting in that one kind of battle I
guess that would it took away from Thor
actually showing up if you had the Hulk
there able to clear out all those are
enemies alright so I guess they rewrote
it but they didn't tell iron studios and
iron Studios has the affinity Warhawk
actually played it I find it funny I
think it's hilarious but I also think
it's a boon for me because again I get a
crazy good piece thank you again for
tuning in to kos see you next week
where I unbox something
the next piece you'll see it's going to
blow your minds hey also stick around
for the unboxing this allows you to
listen to some music while you look at
the video maybe you don't want to hear
my voice see you next week
[Music]